Hi my name is Luca, from LucaLampariello.com, and today we're going to talk about love.
A few weeks ago I was sitting at a
table at a tandem event, and all of a
sudden, someone asked me a very peculiar
question - we were talking about language
learning and it turned out that I speak
a few languages myself, and I had some
foreign partners, and this girl asked me:
"do you pick up girls to learn languages
or do you learn languages to pick up
girls?" And I admit that the question
kind of caught me off guard and got me
thinking at the same time, so I've been
thinking about my experiences and the
lessons I've learned and here it is,
I wanted to share them with you today
The very first important lesson that
I've learned when it comes to speaking
foreign languages with your foreign
partner is that you should at least
speak their language at an intermediate
level. I still remember that when I met
my ex French girlfriend I spoke French
relatively well and the same happened
with my ex Russian girlfriend and I am
sure that if I hadn't spoken those
languages at a good level I would have
never spoken or practiced these
languages because we would have reversed,
we would have resorted to - go figure -
English! And I've learned that once you
start a relationship in a specific
language, that relationship solidifies
and coalesces around the language, and it is
really difficult to change languages,
switch languages down the line, so the
first lesson I've learned is learn
languages because the more languages you
learn, the more opportunities you
have. You never know, maybe today you're
going to stumble upon a girl or a guy
who speaks the language you're learning
and remember: every language you learn
makes you closer to millions of people potentially.
The second important lesson I've learned
is that language learning doesn't happen
automatically in general, and doesn't
happen automatically even if you have a
partner. You still have to put in the
effort. So you might be thinking that
since you have a partner, you might want
to get every chance you get to practice
that language with her or with him, but
your partner is your love partner, you
share love with them, not ...you know.. he or  she is not your language
partner, so you have to make a compromise,
you have to learn but you don't have to
pester them with too many questions
because otherwise they're going to get -
they're gonna get the idea that you are
there to use them. How to do that? My
advice is to keep learning on your own,
get massive input, get into the habit of
listening, reading, and then also on top
of that, if you have the chance of
practicing languages for
example on the internet, or with other
friends that's great! Then
the cherry on the cake is to practice
with your partner, but that's the cherry on the cake, you should do bulk of the work yourself.
The third
lesson I've learned is that when it
comes to having a foreign partner, you
get your fair share of embarrassing
moments, of misunderstandings of misusing
words, or saying one word thinking that
you're saying something while you're
saying something else. Meet the parents
meet the circle of friends. This is all
part of the beautiful adventure of
having a foreign girlfriend or a foreign
boyfriend so I've had my fair share of
embarrassing moments but I accept them
and I know that this is all part of this
beautiful trip that is language learning and getting to know foreign cultures and foreign people.
So here you have it, I hope that it was useful
if you have a tandem, a foreign boyfriend
or girlfriend, please share your stories
your everything - ranging from
embarrassing situations to
lovely moments with your partner,
families and friends. You can click
in the description box to check on the
link to an article that I have written
about this, where I share my very
personal stories and in particular my
first kiss in Ireland and how language
learning played a huge role. Especially
speaking English with an American accent
made all the difference.